I think that this generation honestly
I'm a little ahead of you in the in
terms of generations generations the
worst I just want to take a strong
stance I think though that you can no
longer react like that you know too much
stuff too many phones too many yeah yeah
yeah you everything's caught this yeah -
yeah you don't think that anyone can be
like an old-school diva anymore
I think that like um back in the day
probably
I love old-school divas man like you
like someone like I don't want to name
anybody key died
well not Steve Harvey didn't you just
come out an email what was the email his
demands basic clothes right season
nobody allowed in the office nobody you
know yeah even if we're friends don't
try to walk and talk with me like he was
loud they tried to get him like fired
the one time I saw Steve Harvey at The
Comedy Store yeah he was walking on the
back hallway I swear to [ __ ] god he
goes yo male [ __ ] this place and he spit
on the [ __ ] what because he
auditioned from Mitzi's so many times
apparently oh wow she never passed him
well that was warranted then yeah no I
think that what Mitzi did was what she
did no I'm just saying to have that type
of like no because let me say thing
right now
louis c.k mm-hmm also audition permits
right and she admitted in this is after
his first HBO special goes lyin him he
doesn't have it out loud yeah alright
and he still comes back because he's
smart
louis c.k goes she's a [ __ ] senile
older lady and she doesn't she's on a
touch yeah and then he did a special
there yeah I never got to meet her or
know her I was impressed me and it was
there is something about having
conversations with her that's magical
yeah but she could
I don't want Holly to listen but she
would say things that are so [ __ ]
crazy
yeah that it would [ __ ] up your world I
think really yeah like I remember AJ
Jamal telling me I don't that said have
I said this before AJ Jamal agent you
know AJ Jamal no to first he was on he
was on the last couple of seasons in
living color very funny African American
comedian he said to me when I first came
to LA I go yo don't even I've been a
paid regular here for like 10 years I
when she walks down the hallway I go the
other way
Wow I go why because she could say
something that could completely alter
her yeah because she used to like change
people's names yeah and tell people what
to wear I mean have we talked about
we've talked about Jackie Graham Jackie
Graham was a comic mm-hm
and she goes you're funny and he thinks
your new name is Jackie banana and he
goes okay you have to wear a yellow suit
from now on so he would go up on stage
in the yellow sand and his name was
Jackie banana perfect oh maybe she was
just testing them another I'll give I
have another ones good branding Jackson
Purdue yes you're fun Jackson banana
they fall fruit every time yeah you have
to wear a purple a purple turtleneck so
for like three summers he wore a purple
turtleneck weird even find a print on
something I don't know
yeah he went got it Carlos Mencia wasn't
his name no Carlos didn't change it said
Ned it's Ned he went up as Ned admits he
gave him the nickname Carlos Mencia
she's the one that changed the s John
capper ill oh yeah for four years his
name was John campy so I didn't really
want to get in a conversation I don't
want to be called Bobby Toyota would she
make you wear why would she make you
wear dress like a transformer